leading with empathy is really important  sometimes can  feel a little bit cliche but i think it  is important  and leading with empathy it doesn't mean  that you don't have  high standards it doesn't mean that you  don't hold people accountable  i'm big on accountability accountability  for myself and accountability for my  teams  and we've always had very high standards  but  if those things are in place then the  way that you lead  motivate empower coach so i'd lean  heavily on  on coaching uh to get the best out of  people  but you know those things that's really  kind of the the method  to get to that sort of destination and  so i think kind of treating people  with um treating people with respect  and um and kind of supporting them  meeting them where they are is is really  important  and giving really really clear  [Music]  expectations